welcome so today tier name myself we're
gonna talk to you about what's next but
before we get started we'll want to tell
us a little bit about ourselves
I'm Michael Dawson ibm's community lead
for nodejs what that means is I get to
spend a lot of time in the community
contributing to the different working
groups the strategic initiatives and so
forth like I mentioned before I'm also
have the great privilege to work with a
lot of our internal teams at IBM where
we've done some really cool things like
port v8 to our platforms as 390 and
PowerPC as well as working with the
teams as I mentioned in the past panel
to make sure that you know everywhere
you can deploy nodejs is is great in
terms of the IBM cloud public and
private so awesome I have my dope
I'm turning siren I'm a developer
advocate at note source
I'm chairperson of the node.js community
committee and for I know Dan just talked
about it a bit the community committee
is a top of a committee in the nerdiest
project focused on more of the outward
things in the project so enabling
community building out new programs and
projects for us to continue the growth
in the community I also contribute to
you various working groups and
initiatives across the organization
trying to get as much done around
enabling new developers to use nodejs as
possible I guess that's one of the
things I forgot to mention I'm on the
technical steering committee I know it
has has two top-level committees you
know technical steering committee in the
community committee and we work very
closely to kind of push push forward all
the things that are important to that to
note as as an ecosystem yep so first of
all just wanted to give you a little bit
of an overview about what we're gonna
talk about before we get into it and the
first thing I've titled is like learn
how to fish and the question is well why
do I need to learn how to fish and what
does that mean well I think you know if
you've looked at the project you'll see
that there isn't a well-defined roadmap
you know you can't go somewhere and say
you know in node 12 node 14 these are
the features that you're gonna see
coming in but what that doesn't mean
that doesn't mean that we don't have
longer-term initiatives and longer-term
plans and directions that we're moving
in it's just that because you know no GS
is a very
volunteer-driven organization we don't
know when those things are coming out it
really comes down to individuals or
companies who are contributing to decide
what they think is important work on
those in a collaborative manner and so
when things are ready they'll come out
so we need to learn to fat learn how to
fish because if you want to know what's
next which is what we're talking about
today you need to be able to go and look
at the project and look at the key areas
that we'll talk to you about today to
see what's coming down the pipe
understand what's going on and then you
can figure out for yourself
what's next we'll tell you what we see
is coming up next but you know two
months from now hopefully we've given
you the tools so you can see what's
coming as well yep after that we're
gonna start with some high-level
predictions which have you know what we
thinks coming up will then dive into the
working groups teams to teaching
initiatives which are really good areas
for how you actually figure out what's
next yep so going fishing how do you
track on what's next so at the very
lowest level if you want to figure out
what's going to be available in your LTS
releases you can look at the the other
tiers of releases so in the project we
have current releases we have LTS
releases we even have nightly releases
each of those releases will have a
change log so if you want to know what's
going to be in the next LTS a great way
is to look at the current releases and
see what's going into that current
release and what's available to for you
today because that's very concretely
what's going to be in the next release
the project is also you know very vocal
on social media so things like Twitter
are a good way if you follow you know
the people who are on the community
community the people who are on the
technical steering committee you can get
a feel for what people are talking about
and what's coming down the pipe so one
of the TCC members Gibson Fanshawe put
together a list which is there so if you
want to follow that you can easily you
know follow on the next one is one which
I personally do but I you know I admit
is very challenging is to follow the
github firehose you can basically
subscribe to all the all the the repos
the the project has a really strong
focus of doing everything in a
transparent way as much as possible so
discussions are held in github you know
decisions are made there and so you can
actually see all the discussions and
what's going on in terms of determining
what's going to be next the challenges
there's
laught there you go away for a couple
days like when we go back from the
conference there's probably gonna be
like 2000 issues that people have talked
about and commented on so doing that is
very difficult but it's always one of
the options available to you my more
favorite approach is to start to look at
the working groups and teams along with
the streets you can these initiatives
we're sort of the longer-term bigger
picture things are being worked because
those can give you an idea of what the
the sort of larger functional changes
are going to be or what some of the
bigger problems that the groups are
wrestling with in terms of you know how
do we get mentoring off the ground how
do we get modules in and and you know
even if they're not going to come for
several releases you can figure out what
the the sort of key things the project
is working on so we're gonna each kind
of give some of our high-level
predictions of what's gonna actually
happen a project in the next year two
years five years so you know one of the
things that I I feel really strongly
about is that we're actually gonna be
seeing more convergence around the
different communities that use nodejs
and them getting them getting a more
more of a platform to speak and becoming
more vocal in the project so we see
things like you know front-end tooling
we see things like deploying nodejs
applications on docker or on kubernetes
with docker to really kind of build out
a micro service architecture there's
even things like serverless any kind of
new and emerging platform for node we
need to be enabling that voice and I
think that that's coming down the
pipeline shortly I actually just
published an article that I kind of
wrote about all my thoughts around this
so feel free to take a look at our blog
my blog the don't source blog if you're
interested in that on top of that we're
gonna be engaging with more individuals
that have differing backgrounds and
different kinds of education so that
means you know anything from uni
students to you know two-year boot camp
students to you know self-taught
individuals from you know code Academy
or code school or Pluralsight or any of
the platforms or LinkedIn learning which
you can all go get the the free six free
lessons from so
so you know there's a bunch of different
ways you can begin to approach node and
we're gonna be seeing more and more of
the backgrounds in the communities from
that engaging in the project on top of
that we're gonna be engaging in
discourse with more communities that are
homegrown so nodejs actually has a huge
focus on everything being kind of
community driven so if there's a lot of
communities that already out there
there's a talk about node girls and
there's quite a few other communities so
that's one of the things that I think
we're gonna be engaging with a lot more
read soon on top of that we're gonna be
increasing efforts around
internationalization and actually
getting a broader global reach there's
already an initiative to
internationalization initiative that's
actually a really good platform huge
shout out to the electron folk who have
helped a lot with that and on top of
that we're gonna be engaging with more
people from underrepresented parts of
the ecosystem so things that we don't
already see this kind of ties into a
couple of the other points and finally
we're actually doing quite a bit of work
around the nerdiest website to make it
more than a destination for downloads
and Doc's we're doing quite a bit of
work right now in the website redesign
initiative to really make an attractive
platform for you to kind of come and
engage with nodejs
as it is a language and is a platform
okay so as Dan reminded me in the last
talk you know one of my favorite things
is I think we're gonna see a good
virtuous cycle from our user feedback
initiatives we're really trying to reach
out to more groups who are not that the
ones building nodejs but the ones who
are using nodejs and so I think over the
next year we're gonna see more cases
where we see that input coming into the
project being internalized and it
resulting in us doing things in the
project that help serve those end users
you know a little bit a little bit
better on the technical front you know I
see an API and http2 coming out of
experimental I know any PI has actually
already made it it's it was complete in
ten dot X so that's a great thing HTTP 2
isn't quite there yet but we're hoping
like they may be out of at the end of
August we'll see it in time for $10 so
regardless I think that's you know
something that's coming up we've had a
sort of an ongoing effort to help on the
error message front it relates back to
the internationalization we're moving
from like basically soon
you know solely a string based error
message to a code in a string which
gives us the flexibility to potentially
translate those error messages so I
think we're going to complete that we've
we've done most of the work on the
JavaScript side but we still have some
work on the C++ side which were you know
I think we'll complete this year there
should be a strong emphasis on
Diagnostics we already had the first
diagnostic summit in February in octo
and in January yeah in February in
Ottawa which was quite cold so I a few
people gave me a bit of a give it a bit
of trouble for that but I think that's
just a sign of you know there's a strong
interest in working on the Diagnostics
as a key area in that for this year and
I will see more progress on that front
for sure the security working group has
been doing a great job on ramping up in
terms of doing third-party triage or
triage and vulnerabilities for
third-party modules I don't know if you
watched the security panel earlier but
it was mentioned that we had a little
bit of a lull but we really managed to
sort of ramp that up this year I think
that's only going to continue so we're
gonna see more and more from the
security working group in terms of you
know what can we do in core what can we
do to make those posts more efficient
and make it easier for people to use
nodejs a secure way es6 modules is
another big area we have a great group
of people who have jumped in and are
discussing the very difficult challenge
of how do you you know support our
existing module ecosystem while moving
to compatibility with the web on the es6
front and you know that they've made
good progress on defining the use cases
and I think my prediction is like over
this year we're going to come to
something which will tell us what's
going to be next on that front very
important to a number of people are
promises and we see more and more use of
that so we're already experimenting in
core in terms of their FS and DNS
implementations and we're using that to
sort of figure out what works and what
doesn't so I think again this year we're
gonna see more progress on how we move
towards a promise byte core and then
finally you know workers is another area
where we now have an experimental
implementation but over the next year I
think we'll see a lot of refinement of
that hopefully to the point at least I'm
hoping that we'll get to something where
we actually have a fully supported API
that you can use to leverage other
threads awesome so we're going to go
into kind of a rapid-fire
the different initiatives and working
groups that are in the project right now
and how we can get involved and also
thanking everyone who's been involved
actively in those different things yeah
that's that's really important because
like we're just up here telling you
about a work from a lot of people
different work a lot of difficult on
yeah we're representing the two
different committees and then all the
different groups that those represent we
by no means really represent those
groups in their work there's hundreds of
people so one quick one error messages
so recently we've shipped error messages
Michael mentioned this earlier so you
know there's a lot of work that's been
done on J s error messages and now C++
error messages are coming this is a
super exciting thing because it actually
makes us able to ship changes to error
messages you can see then this in the
slide here that this is th message it
should really be this is the message so
that used to actually be a semi major
change to fix the typo so yeah we're
kind of we've addressed that and we're
able to kind of dig into that awesome
look there you go so on top of that
there's internationalization so like ice
men shinned there's a massive engagement
with this now internationalization was
one of the things I found most
interesting with IO Jaya split there's a
huge international community that came
out and helped us out and we've kind of
seen that dwindle off so we're trying to
reengage with them we're actually
following the process that electron has
built out with using Crowden as a
platform for that and that also right
now is including docs and then beginning
to include the website translations and
we're hoping to be able to move to error
messages as well as short in the near
future so what's new with security well
as I mentioned before the you know the
security working group has been working
over the past year did a great job
ramping up on the third-party triage we
managed to document a number of our
existing processes so for example we now
have you know how do we handle security
releases documented we became a CVE so
we can actually start a a CNA so we can
actually issue our own CVEs and do that
more efficiently in quickly
so really what's next on that front is
to continue to grow the team who triage
as those third-party vulnerabilities
because there's lots of modules out
there and so we need lots of support we
want to reinforce the people who are
helping us so actually getting out there
and evangelizing the ethical hackers who
are looking at node and helping us find
what's going on before it becomes
something that's actually been exploited
we're thinking about you know what do we
do for cv issue issuing CVEs four
modules themselves so far we issue them
for node cord
how do we do that for third party
modules maybe we could become our own cv
issuer maybe we'll leverage the the
hacker one infrastructure and then most
recently one of the the good discussions
is like we're starting to talk about
what should we do in core are there
api's or the things that we should
provide that would actually let you run
code within core in a way that ends up
being a little bit safer so that's sort
of what's next on the security front so
what's next on the diagnostics front you
know really our goal is there or to get
to the point where we have first-class
tracing profiling keep and memory
analysis debugging all the things you
really need to you know make sure that
when things go wrong the production you
have the tools you need to figure out
what's going on on that front what's
next is hardening async hooks async
hooks is a - as a key API that lets you
track what's going on with asynchronous
flow and as we know note is asynchronous
but it's sometimes you know harder to
figure out what's going on that key
things that that are coming up is we're
working on formalization of the async
terminology we want a language we can
actually talk about to each other and
reason with so that's the key thing
we're working on as well as we're
starting to see some of the initial
tools for visualisation you've probably
seen some of the talks on things like
bubble prof which are exploiting async
cooks to give you the information that
you know that you want to be able to see
other things that are being they're
being worked that that should be coming
up as things like postmortem with
promises there's actually some
challenges we move to a world where
promises are used extensively so working
on how we come up with the tools that
will let you do bugs cases where you
know promises have been rejected and
that's not something that you expected
to happen we're talking about
formalizing tiers for support for our
tooling so tooling is is very important
at this point we don't necessarily have
good CI coverage or a good contract that
says when we go out with news
releases how do we make sure all the key
tools are still working so that's an
area that we're working on and and we'll
be next and then pulling in key things
like node report into the runtime itself
so that when you're in production you
have a problem the core things are there
of course not all the tools make sense
to be there but there's sort of a corset
at least in my opinion which just should
be part of the runtime and so pushing
forward so that that corset is there and
then leveraging things like we got a new
trace engine from v8 so be actually
having trace points that you can use to
follow the flow and stuff like that so
in so tierney what's new on the website
website redesign yes so the website
redesign is actually an initiative you
know like I mentioned earlier to
actually go and completely redo the
website it turns out the current design
was a temporary design that we've had
for three years so stops being temporary
at that point but we're actually going
through a full process of going down the
path of collecting it you know building
out the information architecture going
down and getting a design and then
actually going and implementing it this
effort is being led by to the community
committee members Adam and Manila Adams
here somewhere but yes that said it's
super important to actually execute on
this efficiently because the website is
a lot of things for us it can be a place
where the community can come together
and create content regardless of you
know what framework it uses or what
cloud it uses or what what anything it
uses it doesn't matter there's a place
for node content because it's very much
a community project so we're actually in
the design phase right now we've
completed information architecture
stripe has graciously donated three
months of it one of their designers time
to us full-time so a huge shout out to
them for enabling us to actually execute
on that design effectively so you know
we're beyond what we're doing just with
the top level site the documentation is
actually entirely separate from the
notice website he lives in core so we're
working with the run kit team to
actually you know
helped improve the design and
effectiveness of the documentation
itself and that's not easy there's a lot
of Docs and it's a process on top of
that we're gonna be adding those guides
and those resources for you all to
contribute we're gonna be building out a
framework for you to be able to do that
if you're interested and then on top of
that we're still building building out a
community section but a community
section should really be built by the
community and we shouldn't need to get
input on what that should be so that's
not necessarily something that we feel
comfortable dictating at this point on
top of that we're also gonna be trying
to do things around call-outs for
collaborators and contributors to all of
the different parts you know a lot one
of the reasons we included thanks to
everyone in these slides is because
people don't get credit for the a lot of
the work they do especially the
unglamorous work and there's a lot of it
a note there's a lot outside of node
core so you know this is a gonna be a
way that we can actually recognize them
in an official manner and also recognize
people like you know the umpteen service
providers who give us free
infrastructure for our build systems so
you know it's an important thing and
we're very excited to be doing that
there's a lot of different groups and
people and whatever who contribute to
make DEP success and yeah it's really
important to recognize that stuff
absolutely on top of that so there's the
release working group they manage every
single release of note when a new
release comes out so their goals are
really to ship releases that don't have
bugs that don't have an issue that it's
a smooth project from the build being
done to actually having it in your hands
on your machine in the cloud
so that's what they do and they you know
as a part of that they do backporting
they backport features from no 10 - node
6 and no date there's a lot of work here
and this is one of those things that
stipulate that typically goes under the
radar and it's kind of uncle amorous but
it's one of the most vital and important
parts of the ecosystem for us is a
project so you know in that what's
coming next
is we're actually trying to get more
people on boarded I believe we've just
gotten a couple shell Eve or who
done a few things here I know she's you
know been on boarded and we were also
adding a couple more yes it's really
around making it more of a team effort
yes it's like it's it's it's hard
because there's some things that really
sort of serialized the effort but we
want to do what we can to make sure it's
a team effort we can rely on more other
people to make exactly and then on top
of that you know building out a safety
net of you know we're not gonna be
caught at a moment when we don't expect
to be caught so that very much goes to
what you're saying yeah awesome so
what's new in the the building
automation working group so this is the
group that helps keep all the
infrastructure going that we need for
for nodejs you know one of the key
things it's just an ongoing thing
there's more automation and tools and
scripts becoming more efficient in
particular people are working on a
commit cue so that's something we may
see in the next year we're all commits
are landed automatically without people
having to be you know manly and manually
involved in that effort we're working on
improving our ansible coverage ansible
is the tool we use to deploy our
different virtual machines where we run
the tests and you know there's a focus
on tracking intermittent failures in the
CI so that we can actually make sure
that those intermittent failures don't
slow us down which we we often see that
they do today some of the things is sort
of what's coming next in terms of you
know and we'll continue to see this is
that we're driven to have different
levels that are supported in operating
system levels compiler levels and as
things become either unsupported or
obsolete we're forced to move up and
that's something that can affect you so
you know I suggest you keep an eye on
the the requirements in the building got
MD for each release and so that you know
when you know maybe your favorite
operating system maydel may or may not
longer may or may not be supported
anymore wondering and one of the more
interesting things about that recently
was actually 32-bit builds right and in
fact that you know for master or for
actually 410 I think we dropped 32-bit
yields and so you know keeping keeping
on those things because we do those you
know basically make our best decision on
what makes sense yeah we actually went
and looked at the data that built data
for all of the downloads and there was
hardly any 32-bit downloads so it
doesn't make sense for us to actually
add that additional layer of complexity
of them down load of matrix or the
matrix of downloads so those are the
kind of things that are coming on the
building automation it's like more
automation
our internal processes and the kind of
compiler operating system things that
are sort of pushed on to us by
continuing you know movement forward so
what's new in terms of the benchmarking
working group you may have mentioned
that you know in the cloud there's some
discussion of that as well you know our
key goals are just to do what we need to
do to avoid regressions and evangelize
you know increases in performance how do
we do that we build use cases we
identify benchmarks cover those use
cases and we run in capture of the
results so really what's next on that
front is new workloads I personally
think that you know one that hopefully
we'll get in is covering promises
because we see that as them being used
more and more so we want to make sure
that whatever we do in core doesn't do
anything to regress performance on that
front awesome so we have a few new
initiatives around community building so
one of them is actually the mentorship
initiative dan who is muttering the last
panel he's been participating it as a
have a suite of others who are actually
mostly new to the project and we're
trying to kind of push toward mentoring
both how to use nodejs and also
mentoring how to contribute to no js' so
there's you know we've done a lot of
effort one of the one of the
contributors akhmad actually went and
went through and built out the entire
framework and we base it off of that but
you know we we're always looking for
mentors we've had about 300 people sign
up less I checked to actually be mentees
but if any of y'all are interested in
helping mentor people who are wanting to
jump into node we'd really love to have
you because we don't have enough mentors
on top of that patricia Dugan who you
know was on my panel yesterday she's
kicking off reigniting node together
with the goal of actually going after
community colleges so I myself went to a
community college and you know having
the experience they're there she's
taking a very good approach where she's
actually going after a place where
there's a low rate of graduation one of
my professors tell me was about 18% for
the college I went to there's a lot of
people from underrepresented minorities
and then there's a ton of Technology to
be able to use to actually enable node
together so that checks up all the boxes
the things we had a little bit of a
rough time with previously is getting
the people from underrepresented
minorities which is what note together
is intended to do is actually help get
those people into node and then have
technology available and also you know
be in a place where you know we kind of
need to be doing this so yeah the next
thing is a module so this is a huge
effort another one my panelists Tara and
also the MC she's been involved in this
pretty heavily as have you know got a
ton of others I think when it started
there was about 50 people contributing
yeah it was like 40 50 people jumped in
said because that's how interested
people yeah yeah and so this is a really
hard problem Myles Boren's is also doing
an amazing job managing this but there's
a lot of people trying to work this out
and work this problem out
they're doing a lot of work on getting
this done we already have a basic
implementation shipped but it's not the
one that we're gonna land on as far as I
know so we're actually still continuing
the the modules team is still going out
and actually building up the use cases
of okay why would you want to use ESM
with commonjs and then actually once we
have that fully documented we're gonna
be able to go and actually refine the
experience experiments and make sure
we're actually hitting all the use cases
okay so the next one you know what's new
with some of the strategic initiatives
HTP doing the first one so you know it's
background it's a major revision to HTTP
2 it provides a lot of really
interesting things in terms of being
able to achieve better performance by
doing things in parallel doing things
ahead of time it's currently
experimental under but there's no flag
required so you can try it out as I
mentioned before you know one of my
hopes is that you know it will be not
experimental this year and and even
possibly in 10 um it provides you two
new core API is one which is something
that's more familiar to what you would
have used in core and that's
compatibility API and then the core API
which is closer to the underlying ng
HTTP to C++ implementation which is
different but will let you you know take
advantage of more of the things you're
getting in the new HTTP HTTP to support
and only what's neck
there's you know expected to expect exit
experimental in 2018 what's next on any
pie basically you know any pie provides
you an a bi-stable module an API and a
bi-stable API that native modules can
use so that when you build your native
modules they can run with multiple
versions of node it no js' and you won't
have to necessarily recompile your
module or change your code what's next
on that front is we're really focusing
on the docs and tests for no data on API
which is the C++ wrapper that you can
use to use it it's already stable in in
10 dot X master it's already in 6 & & 8
so you can use it there but basically
what's next is it's going to become
stable in 8x with the next ember release
and 6 dot X is it's more as you know
it's already there you can use it it's
only doc experimental and depending on
sort of the the usage feedback we get
you know we'll figure out whether we
need to change that and so for the team
you know what we're focusing on beyond
that is driving adoption working with
the module owners and so forth
the next strategic initiative is core
promise API is a touched on that quickly
so you know there's a couple of
experimental implementations and really
what's next is you know figuring out
what works what doesn't and then
figuring out the plan to roll out to the
rest of the API the other one I already
mentioned which was workers so being
able to do some of your computation off
of the main thread we have a
experimental implementation in core and
so what's next is really for people to
collaborate main you know refine that
implementation and move to the point
where like we can define a set of exit
criteria and get to the point where it's
stable if I remember quickly we're
actually running all the CI builds with
the workers flag that's one of the the
recent you know milestones is that
there's testing so that you know that is
definitely one of the great milestones
so yeah one of the things I think Dan
talked about a bit I wasn't paying
attention because I was getting backed
up but you know one of the things didn't
talked about is actually user feedback
this is a super important thing to
actually begin to collect feedback from
distinct communities so this is both for
internal working groups and also for the
communities to have more of a voice in
node and so you know we've already seen
a few groups
break out of the mold we kind of had for
them so we've seen this with the tooling
working group or not the tooling working
group the tooling user feedback yep
we're gonna have to create a new acronym
for that I know and it's great to see
them sort of go out where we'll still be
there to you know help make sure that
there's a strong link to the project but
the group is sort of forming their
identity and running with their you know
the agenda that they need to push
forward yeah yeah and so that's been a
super exciting thing and we've also seen
this a little bit with enterprise so
yeah that's a very exciting thing for us
to be able to kind of continuously get
feedback from individuals who are highly
invested in each of the different areas
that no does touch so we're actually
beginning to explore new ways we've been
new ways to engage with end-users that
we haven't really done before one of the
things we discussed in the last general
meeting was actually having like an
online meetup because note is global
like there's hundreds of thousands of
developers using node around the world
and we're not gonna be able to access
them very simple I think the key point
there is we were talking about it as a
new channel not everybody's comfortable
with getting into github and using
issues up and that's that that you know
that there's already an infrastructure
there for people getting together and
people may be more comfortable with that
yep but that's definitely something on
the forefront yeah absolutely so this is
all been into the node.js project under
the community committee or under the TSC
there's actually the node.js foundation
was which has a lot of its own
initiatives that kind of why outside of
either of those groups they participate
but they're not necessarily driven by
those groups so the foundation has
actually been working on a node.js
certification for a long time we've it
kind of died down for a while
to work on it but we've recently picked
it back up I've been contributing pretty
heavily to that as have you know David
mark Clements from your forum Nathan
white from node source and a few others
okay the hook hasn't come oh my god so
bad yeah yeah so you know you know we've
been working on the certification and
that's actually hopefully you know
progressing well shortly here on top of
that we have the noches collection which
is a media publication where we accept
blog posts on medium from community
members so there's quite a few there oh
yeah I haven't actually
this statistic in quite a while and then
we're you know continuing to try to grow
interaction in the jas ecosystem so
actually you know having the foundation
booth here is definitely something that
is kind of precedent setting for the
foundation it's something they've been
playing with a lot recently on top of
that they've been doing a lot of no J's
case studies with enterprises so if you
do work at a company or you know a
start-up not just an enterprise but a
come you know a company that's
interested in actually working with the
node.js foundation to do a case study
and discuss how you use no you keep
going keep going
your I know I know I'm just playing yeah
to discuss how you use node that'd be
fantastic love Cara keep going that's
how you're using node we'd love to have
you and then you know there's there's a
lot more stuff coming down the pipeline
and if you have any ideas of what the
foundation could do to kind of help
enable you to use node more we'd love to
hear that so on that this is the last
slide Oh keep going there's plenty of
time
they won't serve beer until we give the
signal and by the way once they're done
please stay around for just a couple
minute and their reward for doing so is
someone in Saudi answers gonna get a
free pass for next year which we'll talk
about that's good excellent
so back to the talk we've had we very
intentionally included the names of the
working group members and initiative
members on every side of when we were
discussing the working groups and
initiatives because Michael and I are up
here on stage as two leaders elected
leaders of the TSC and community
committee that said you know one thing
that we've discussed a lot has been that
we're not actually like the leader in
the head and the btfl of the TSC and
community committee we're just
contributors that also take on a bunch
of administrative work a lot of
administration and so everyone who's
kind of stepped up and we listed in
these slides is someone who came because
they were interested in it or because it
helped them do what they want to do and
that could be you too so we'd really
love to have you come and contribute if
there's something on one of these slides
of is interesting
you or if there's something we're not
already doing around a technical project
or the community building out something
new we'd really love to have your input
your feedback in your contributions into
the project so I'll just close with come
out and help us make what's next thanks
everyone
[Applause]